it's a town that was founded by
Methodist ministers in the late 1800s
and it was a town that carries some of
the Victorian virtues and vices of the
present day so while I was born there in
1932 and grew up in the world war two
years of the mid-40s I think it's shaped
me in the sense of giving me a sense of
the middle of America divorced from the
urban sophistication of New York where I
have lived the last 50 years and given
me a sense of a kind of small town or
what Hillary Clinton would call a
village mentality I think that's what
I've always had I've lived in New York
they said for most of my adult life and
much of the time when I first arrived in
New York I was a reporter for The New
York Times that was from the mid 50s to
the mid 60s but no matter what kind of
story I was doing or later on articles
for magazines and still later books that
I was writing I always had a vision of
where I come from and I measured the
people i'm writing about or whatever it
is i'm trying to describe from the
vantage point of the people that I grew
up with
it made me feel isolated in a spiritual
sense although I didn't have a bunch of
a spiritual sense even when I was a
practicing Catholic because they did
have a sense of not entirely belonging
but that wasn't due to the Catholicism
so much as being an Italian I'm Italian
image my parents are from Italy and I
had in his Irish Catholic parish a sense
of being a minority person within the
minority church in a Protestant town I
didn't feel I really belonged in any way
fully I didn't believe I belong in the
United States in a full sense because
when I was growing up it was that the
1940s and Italy was at war with the
United States and my fathers brothers
were all the italian army fighting
against the american invasion which
began 1942 in that part of the
Mediterranean and so when I was growing
up at age you know 11 12 13 in the in
the Warriors of the 40s I didn't know
entirely whose side we were on in a
private sense I knew in a public sense
he has very patriotic and you had to be
as immigrants very defensive people most
many of them if not most I certainly was
had a sense of defensiveness about my
origins and also the Catholicism I
mentioned before was not totally
accepting of the of the Italians because
they were in the lower level of the
pecking order the Irish were low enough
but we were even lower than that and the
Irish came to America in the 1840s as
you know your history at least speaking
the language it's very important when
you're an immigrant class of an
immigrant class if you come fortified
with the with the language you are a
generation ahead of where the rest of
them are the Jews or the Italians came
about the same time in large large
numbers in the 1890s and up to World War
World War one and it didn't have a
language so there's that whole
generation that has to readjust not only
in language but sometimes and beyond
culture sometimes even changing their
names to try to fit in I mean that many
of the Italians and many of the Jewish
people of the per period before the turn
of the of the 20th century
change their names try to be more
readily accepted because their names
were unpronounceable or they felt very
foreign themselves so language was a
problem I grew up in 19th i was born in
32 and i never had the language problem
but i did have a sense within myself of
a fractured being a fractured person
which greatly helped me when i started
writing about other people because i
always had from my early days as a
journalist which started really in high
school I always had a sense of what is
it like for other people to be other
people and how they different from me so
I had a detached sense of self which I
think was very good
we spoke English and the reason being
that my mother and father ran a shop on
the main street of the town Protestant
town I emphasize the money was with the
Protestants and the people who came to
my father's my mother's dress shop which
was a very popular place on the Main
Street whirr whirr of the wasp culture
they were the upper middle class or the
upper class of the town they were women
whose husbands made most of the money in
the town they were the wives of the
mayor and the lawyers and the
superintendent of schools and that the
leading businessmen the the ford dealer
the buick dealer and they would drag
they would buy these women and
middle-aged was it was a not a
fashionable shop but a shop for the
refine affluent middle class and these
women would spend a good deal of money
on clothes more than the more youthful
shops on the other side of the street
and they would be my mother's favorite
customers and my mother would very much
watch how they behave and listen to the
way they spoke and learn a lot about
their lives as they conversed over the
counter in ways that was instructive for
her and as I was an eavesdropper after
school after parochial school would hang
around the shop and perform menial tasks
I would overhear these conversations and
I would get as I would later as a
journalist get get a sense of other
people and how they lived it was a
sociological experience
you